KEVIN JULIAN: Hello, and
welcome to our session
covering breakthrough insights
across the life sciences value
chain.
I'm Kevin Julian,
senior managing director
in Accenture's life
sciences practice.
And later I'll be joined by
my colleague, Mike Stapleton,
who's the head of strategy
for Accenture's life sciences
INTIENT platform.
During this session,
we'll be talking
about why creating breakthrough
insights in life sciences
is more important than ever.
And we'll share how INTIENT,
Accenture's life sciences
platform powered by Google, is
able to generate insights using
leading-edge Google technology.
During this session, we'll spend
most of the time illustrating
examples of how insights are
being generated by INTIENT
across the life sciences
value chain, from earlier
research through
pivotal clinical trials
all the way through to
delivering care to patients.
Our industry is at
a turning point,
shifting from small
molecule, large population
strategic approaches to a more
targeted scientific approach.
This shift is powered by what
we Accenture call New Science.
New Science is a novel
chemistry or biology
in previously unsolved
areas of need,
like cell and gene therapy,
often enabled by technology
to deliver the
therapy or to support
the patient, or sometimes
maybe technology
itself, an app or other
technology solution
that intervenes in
an effective way
to improve the
patient [INAUDIBLE]..
Why the shift?
Something had to change.
The old model simply
was not supporting
the needs of the market.
New Science is attracting
significantly more attention
and investment, and
for good reason.
Accenture Research is determined
that New Science therapies are
almost 50% more
likely to be approved
and greater than 50% of sales
over the next several years
are expected from New Science.
This shift to New Science
brings the industry's dependence
on technology to the fore.
Increasingly, industry
depends on connecting data
across the enterprise
to generate insights
into how therapies should
be developed and brought
to patients.
While this ambition is
clear, it's also clear
that industry has yet to take
the necessary actions needed
to achieve their goal.
According to this IDC study,
more than 50% of respondents
did not have a clear path to
connect, share, and analyze
information across
their organization.
This is where INTIENT comes in.
INTIENT, Accenture's platform
for the life sciences industry,
powered by Google Cloud, enables
insights and collaboration
across the life
sciences enterprise.
INTIENT helps the industry
generate breakthrough insights
in three powerful ways--
through functionally
oriented product suites
that have been built in
key areas of insight need--
drug research, clinical
trials, pharmacol vigilance,
and patient services--
with other use cases enabled
by the INTIENT core platform,
and through additional use cases
enabled by the INTIENT network,
our open ecosystem
access solution.
Through access to innovative
specialty software, services,
hardware content, and
other business partners,
the INTIENT network offers
industry-standard APIs
for pretty competitive
functions that
easily and quickly integrate
into existing systems.
The ability to rapidly
and flexibly deploy
solutions and lower
barrier to entry
for new, small, and/or
niche software players--
all of this is made possible
by the INTIENT core platform
powered by Google Cloud.
The core platform is a
flexible and powerful
data-centric solution
that connects
a variety of data
sources and makes
insight generation possible.
How does it do that?
We start by using
Google's Healthcare
API to accelerate
solution development
and access third-party
solutions with fully
managed enterprise scale,
FHIR, HL7, and DICOM API.
We use Google's
BigQuery to analyze
virtually unlimited
amounts of data
using standard SQL at scale
with zero operational overhead.
And AutoML provides
non-expert users with access
to pre-configured, high-quality
machine learning models,
such as image
detection, translation,
and natural language processing.
Let's illustrate the power of
INTIENT with a few examples.
To start, my colleague,
Mike Stapleton,
will share some of
the exciting insights
our clients are generating
with INTIENT Research.
Mike?
MICHAEL STAPLETON:
Thank you, Kevin.
In the next section
of our presentation,
we're going to bring
the power of INTIENT
to life, looking at
three critical parts
of the pharmaceutical
value chain.
I'll start with research,
as Kevin mentions.
I'll then go through
clinical trials,
and then hand back to Kevin,
who will take it home,
connecting the value of research
and development to the patient
and the impact we can have
on us and society in general.
So let's start with research and
the fundamental challenges that
face drug discovery scientists.
Whether they're
starting with a disease
or starting with a target
or starting with a biomarker
discovery program, or, indeed,
repurposing existing research
efforts, in every
single case, drug
discovery scientists
are challenged,
bringing together a wide
range of external data, lots
of historic, hard-to-retrieve
internal data,
assembling that data, bringing
it together in a format
that can be easily
managed, easily visualized,
and decisions taken from
that aggregated data.
Consistently across the whole
of drug discovery research,
that integration of
data, that thinking
through a single query, how
easy it is to make a decision,
and how we can embed
advanced tools--
artificial intelligence,
machine learning--
so that more informed decisions,
more informed predictions
can be made to advance faster
and in a more focused way.
To bring this to
life, I'm going to dig
into one of these
in a bit more detail
and take a look at
target discovery
as a particular example
to show the power
of the INTIENT platform.
The key challenge here,
quite easy to state,
is that as an
industry, as a society,
we know more and more
about human disease biology
than we ever have done.
And we continue to learn more
and more on a daily basis.
Through the advances in
genomics to the connectivity
and measurements of mobile
devices that we all wear today,
we understand more
and more about us
as patients and how
that information
is connected to a therapeutic
or a particular condition
or a lifestyle that we
have as individuals.
But even with that, yet
roughly 90% of candidate drugs
fail in the clinic.
And a large number of those
fail because in early-stage drug
discovery, we still
choose poor targets.
This has the obvious
consequences to the industry--
long development
times, increased cost,
and, quite significantly,
negative patient outcomes.
So if we have the opportunity,
as we do with a platform
strategy like INTIENT, to
address this key bottleneck,
this key area of
pharmaceutical R&D,
we would, quite clearly,
have huge impact.
So why is it so difficult?
Let's have a look at the
operational consequences
of drug discovery today.
Very diverse skill
sets are required
to manually bring together that
external and internal data.
Integration of that data
is extremely time consuming
and often error-prone.
Key patterns, key
indications, key predictions
can only be made
through machine learning
and artificial
intelligence capabilities,
not by the human mind.
And so that's where the
INTIENT solution comes in.
We can use the INTIENT solution
to bring in those broad array
of data sources.
We can aggregate those data
sources, filter, pre-process,
and present the data in a much
more meaningful and accessible
way to a scientist, through
dashboards, alerts, predictions
that allow scientists to better
prioritize, better guide,
and allow a portfolio
activity of project teams
to better manage assets and to
move forward through the drug
discovery process, ultimately
identifying novel targets
and prioritizing
targets which have
a much higher
probability of success
further into
pharmaceutical development.
Let's take a look at
a screenshot of how
that would actually look.
And we see here a simple screen
shot of a modern user interface
from INTIENT, where
we bring together
that drill-down of
both therapy, genome,
and target, and that
important interplay
for a drug discovery
scientist to make
all of those connections
through a simple interface,
to click, to understand,
and to predict.
But obviously,
underneath all of this,
what is powering all of this,
what makes all of this possible
is the INTIENT data fabric--
how we actually ingest
those broad sources of data,
how we present those
analytic viewpoints
so that they are useful and
guide in an intelligent way,
how we support, as
Kevin mentioned,
the broad range of both
chemical and biological
research that now is
just part of the armory
for our pharmaceutical
research scientists.
And how, ultimately, we action--
how do we actually
inform partner companies,
other scientists,
colleagues across the globe
to do something as a consequence
of our insight through a very
integrated request
management capability?
So you can see at all levels
here in drug discovery,
in pharmaceutical
research, how INTIENT
and how the platform
that Kevin described
addresses the key bottlenecks--
the bringing together the data,
aggregating the data,
and presenting it
in an actionable and
predictable fashion.
Success in research
then takes us forward
into pharmaceutical development.
So let's take a similar
view of clinical trials.
And we start in a
very similar way.
We start with the complexity
of managing very large, very
diverse sets of data,
both internal and external
to the pharmaceutical
company, hundreds
of patients across dozens of
sites globally being monitored
and tested and the data from
all of those patients in minute
detail being brought
together for future analysis,
prediction, and
regulatory filing--
hugely complex logistics that
require a scale of computation
to cleanse, process,
and integrate
that data across broad
ranges of genetics, genomics,
mobile data, real-world
data, so that ultimately, we
can create insights,
presenting that aggregated data
in real time so the
prediction can be made
and analysis made to actually
guide future trial design,
to inform conduct and
commercial viability,
and to ultimately facilitate
the filing of a new drug
to the regulatory authorities.
Let's take a look at clinical
operations as one example
here of how all
this comes together.
The challenge being, as I
just stated, bringing together
those very large, diverse
formats and sources of data
from numerous internal systems
across a pharmaceutical company
and significant sources of
information from partner CROs.
And this leads, this challenge
leads to inconsistency,
leads to delays in
actually changing
trial guidelines,
and ultimately,
increases costs and time.
So what makes operations
in clinical different,
as we asked the question in
research a few moments ago?
Again, we still might see
similar patterns here.
Integration of those
disparate data sources
is fundamental,
extremely time consuming,
and extremely expensive.
Effective monitoring
requires access
to comprehensive
and timely data.
And trends in clinical
trials are complex
and require incredibly
complex interactive analyses.
So again, we see how the
INTIENT solution, the platform
capabilities addressing these
complexities and challenges
facing clinical operations--
robust, flexible data
ingestion, transformation
of that data in a way
that makes the data usable
and actionable, actions
to actually remediate
issues in a much more timely
fashion, and visualizations
through interactive
dashboards, predictive tools,
predictive simulation,
and analytics methods.
So again, if we go to
look at a screenshot here,
we can see how all
this comes together--
a single viewpoint, a clinical
control tower, if you like,
a visualization of the
state of a particular trial
or a set of trials,
how we monitor these
through that dashboard,
how we see red, amber,
and yellow indicators to
easily flag activities that
are on track or are not on
track and require action,
how we can drill down into
problematic areas, regions,
countries, sites, and
particular patient demographics,
and how those reports
can easily be accessed
by all leadership and scientists
and medical practitioners
collaborating globally
on a particular program.
So with both research
and clinical,
we've seen how the common
themes of data integration,
aggregation and
presentation about data,
our analysis and visualization
and prediction of that data
comes together through INTIENT.
A success, then, means
we move to the patient.
And Kevin will take it from here
to explain how the value of R&D
is then accelerated through
greater patient engagement.
KEVIN JULIAN: Thanks, Mike.
And indeed, even if one were
to identify the best research
target and successfully take
it through clinical trials
with all the capabilities
that Mike just described,
it wouldn't achieve
its ultimate potential
if we didn't solve for the
needs of the patients we're
targeting here.
INTIENT helps life
sciences organizations
get closer to the patient
through our INTIENT Patient
solution.
Capabilities include
integrating patient care, which
supports better treatment
outcomes, real-world outcomes
research, creating
greater understanding
of clinical and economic
value, patient engagement
support, which improves
initiation and compliance
to prescribe treatments,
and precision medicine
delivery, which provides
needle-to-needle support
for new treatment programs.
All of those are important.
But let's focus on
integrated patient care.
With INTIENT Patient,
we're enabled
to allow physicians to prescribe
digital support programs,
allowing patients to
use devices and apps,
and all connected by INTIENT
Patient to manage their care.
We allow their care providers
to monitor that care,
analyze, and make
recommendations
to improve the care program.
All of this,
importantly, enables
us to lower costs,
improve patient adherence,
and ultimately improve
patient outcomes.
Let's take a look at an example
of our digital patient study
solution, which provides a tool
for principal investigators
to cohesively manage virtual
study and performance.
With INTIENT Patient,
we can manage and track
patient enrollment across sites,
easily configure and provision
the devices that patients use,
track adherence to protocols,
and make early interventions
that prevent patient dropout
from the clinical trial,
and leverage insights
learned through the trial
to ultimately create
an even better patient
experience when that therapy is
brought to market.
All of these
capabilities together
and the insights that
are derived from them
help our life sciences
customers develop
therapies that are
built and delivered
with the patient in mind.
Those are the
examples of insights
that we've generated across the
life sciences value chain using
INTIENT, life sciences--
Accenture's life science
platform powered by Google.
If you have any questions,
our contact information
is on this slide.
And we'd be happy
to answer them.
Now, it's for me to
thank you for joining
us to learn more about
generating breakthrough
insights across the life
sciences value chain.
Thank you.